[Music]
and strong and independent news That's
not me at all
you're very dependent and very weak yep
I need to be on a titty 24/7 I like that
too
submitted by Tiffany's secret admirer
you should I'm gonna tell Casey yep
what is that I said she's this you
shouldn't have a secret admirer because
you're married I know people can admire
from a distance I admire a lot of people
actually creep how so today was about
the policy know what the hell's going on
so that's not creepy at all I just
admire the person from a distance
because if I meet them in person
imma [ __ ] hate them I don't like it
either but God knew California attempts
to declare independence from the rest of
California and a bid to become the 51st
state state states again they're trying
to do this again No so before they were
trying to split California to six states
now they're this new California is just
trying to separate itself from the
coastal city so there's new towel that
oh this is what it would look like is it
all the [ __ ] [ __ ] City it's the
[ __ ] districts that's so true it's
the [ __ ] side of California so
better be to go back to where you came
better people Riverside noting light
Riverside yeah it's the last year a
different group not this is not part of
the same new California a different
group was trying to split California
into six different states and this is
what it would look like so it'd be like
the state of Jefferson North California
what is this Silicon Valley and yeah all
that but then now the new California
they're proposing California to look
like this
holy [ __ ] so this is new California and
this will just become the other one
lakes and eagles are part of them
yeah and San Jose - well why are we like
[ __ ] to them nas because our rules
probably don't match with their rules I
dislike this very much just because that
is a [ __ ] ugly shape for a state
that's like Vietnam it's pretty stupid
why is every other state a nice shape
and this right here looks like somebody
toward toilet paper or some [ __ ] I
actually like the other one can you go
back to the other one getting some
[ __ ] graphic design rules and [ __ ]
now calm the [ __ ] no but this one this
one this one makes sense cuz Silicon
Valley has its own culture West
California has Central Valley like it's
desert no one wants to live there
farmland
you know this is all the gay hipster and
entertainers all here right and then
this is all the [ __ ] California
that's why mmm the Jefferson is the tree
huggers this is this is this makes sense
because no we should not send you a to
San Jose in California that's part of
Silicon Valley yeah this one [ __ ] - it's
true yeah that's weird
this is weird this is LA oh no that's
Orange County okay so what they're how
they're separating this is it's where
the KKK is likely to exist in San Diego
Chifa and little liberal crazy people
are yeah I will say this though they put
Sacramento into the og California
because it is the state capital yep just
wanted to put that out there second let
me let me guess why okay this is the
reason why because the big city [ __ ]
decisions shouldn't affect the small
farming areas I can see that they're
pretty much saying that it's like
uncover Anibal the way things are right
now and so they're new california is
proposing that they can just govern
themselves that they don't need to be
part of the state of the Automator
optional decisions
jealous that I didn't get invited to the
new party so you want to be part of new
California I don't even care what it
stands for I just want to be in the new
new you no no I mean like I just wanted
and if it what you know that Fresno is a
part of that new news I'll stay here I
wonder if they're gonna keep the name
new California yeah just give it
different name no that's what they want
it just like New Mexico New Hampshire Oh
so we'll be California and they'll be
new California New York and Hampshire
hmm cuz just saying it's like new New
Mexico and me I didn't know referring
back to the old country in the in
Britain there was a Hampshire yeah yeah
she was trying to make a joke so let's
just leave no I was it okay yeah I
wasn't earning a Charles to help you out
there I just sounded stupid oh don't
talk about yourself like that I don't
[ __ ] we don't do that let me do that for
you yeah it's very depressing
conversation yeah but they're saying
that the current state of California
right now has just become it has become
governed by tyranny tyranny tyranny it's
raining yeah I know attorney California
Republic it reminds me of People's
Republic of China anytime there's like a
republic the People's Republic a that
word it sounds like either Star Wars and
evil or communist I think it's the Old
Republic Republic oh that's yeah you
don't know anything about Star Wars I've
watched the movies but I just can't like
it just my brain doesn't want to save
that information I don't know it's okay
I'm not really offended oh [ __ ] oh
everybody's like you don't know math
Darwin shut the [ __ ] up
well I actually love Star Wars but I
don't hate on people who don't know
anything about it that's because
cult-like fans yeah are just [ __ ]
idiots do they don't have anything to
live for yes that's why it's all they
care about is that one yeah they care
about it more than their own health yeah
well yeah I imagine let's just pretend
cuz a lot of people are here or saying
like this ain't gonna happen
now just pretend it happens like ya what
woody you know LA San Francisco and what
was that San Jose or Silicon Valley or
LA that alone there's enough [ __ ]
money there to whatever homies I'm not
even trying to go to the other places
except for San Diego yeah you know what
do all the other orange areas that's
where you can shoot [ __ ] I know how
maybe it's yellow golden is golden
yellow what does it say golden yellow
what the [ __ ] is Eureka is that where
they found bald you know what's too bad
about this all the best schools are
gonna be in California to new California
have all the wax schools
Oh like Cal State Fredro and you're
right this is all like farming land
reading Chico a bunch of oranges and
[ __ ] and a bunch of drug dealers
so does Fresno a large drug dealers to
study in San Jose it's like desert land
versus beach land yeah cuz I mean
everyone from the oil from new
California if they want to go to a good
school they have to go out of state now
I don't even have one good school and
I'll have to pay the out-of-state
premium which is Allah oh that's right
cuz UC Riverside UC San Diego like ever
trying to go to Berkeley Stanford LA SC
you big travel man Fresno State San Jose
state's Chico State Oh big trouble yeah
big trouble isn't California's economy
like pretty up there like it's enough to
be its own country
yeah his top ten in the world there was
a group trying to do a cal exit kind of
like the bricks it yeah why would the
u.s. ever let us go they when they want
it cuz
moneymaker yeah that's why that so much
like just fresh produce come from
California alone it's like man I have so
much pride in this state which I have
absolutely no [ __ ] contribution for
but I feel so proud of it you pick taxes
yeah what are you talking about yeah I
know but that's like man I didn't grow
those potatoes you know to me like it's
like you know we supply the rest of the
nation with produce and we have
Hollywood here we're the world's
entertainment or expert we're exporting
la culture to the world that's why I
love California every time I go to a
different state the foods are very
limiting oh we got you with the food
conversation you call them [ __ ] you
know you know those other [ __ ]
[ __ ] states right that's true that's
true
I'm saying it's pretty [ __ ] dope and
you know what it come here the people
think that California is a bunch of
liberals and all that like left-wing
people uh-uh
we got our fair share of Trump
supporters and right-wing people all you
got to do is go to the new California
side they're there you you go to you you
drive up the mountains and see a bunch
of cabins they're the same yeah you
so what we're diverse we got both sides
well not a three we split and new
California be a red state I know
yeah I don't know man California's just
dope dude laughter you travel around
your daughters like comedy shows in
these other states I'm not saying that
the [ __ ] States I am we're making a
Donald Trump why do all these [ __ ]
people from [ __ ] States want to come
to California like they should stay
because especially LA Trump I know it's
kinda really doing the same thing all
the actors though yeah that's what I'm
saying so there's so many [ __ ] people
that transplant here to LA they live
here for a year or two they think
they're [ __ ] Angelenos right and then
they all live around Santa Monica
Hollywood in the valley and then they go
back because they're acting dreams
didn't come true and then they're
talking [ __ ] about LA because oh la
people are so fake this and that you
didn't even
can hang out with real la people with
all the other transplants all the
wannabes yeah that's not [ __ ] la
homie it's interesting especially like
if you're gonna line into the acting
realm
everybody talks us oh now you're so part
of that realm
actually I don't thank you oh you do
like three editions now and like that's
pretty dope by the way you're the only
one of us here that's ever been in a
movie good job good job David
Wow I will tell you this though because
it's such a new experience for me
because I've never been in around actors
before like you know us we create our
own content we're creators we're a
little different you know we're you know
people in a completely different
generation some from old old acting how
much ass-kissing that goes along and how
they speak it how they behave is so
weird and I think like I stick out like
a sore thumb because like you'll see
that interaction and it's just like this
the whole time to the producer basically
hey how are you oh my god you know and
they're dressed up and their nicest
clothes and make they look clean and I
show up like a Japanese [ __ ] tuna
farmer I'm like yo I don't belong here
you do belong here you need to change
that [ __ ] I can't change that [ __ ] like
I don't know if it's a good or bad thing
for me though like you know to be good I
can't I can't really do that so it's not
my thing because we're where we started
from creating our own content so when I
walk it's like for example like I went
to this audition and it meaning when
you're going on dishes you probably
shouldn't say what's on your mind
immediately I probably shouldn't have
said that but I don't I don't know like
I don't know what you're supposed to get
etiquette yeah that's good for you
though maybe see who you are you're
gonna change the game you're gonna shake
you up yeah you'll never get again maybe
I'll just get one if I'm gonna take a
chance but I always like say what's on
my mind first you know and then we were
doing this like this table read for like
this the script and I was just one of
the people that are just gonna act out a
couple of characters but you're supposed
to introduce yourself if somebody goes
well I'm from Stockton I'm like yeah
that sucks they're cracking up but I'm
like if that didn't go over so well it
probably would have been a good thing
but you know hey this is what it is
[Music]
[Music]